en un cuestionario de mate gana 5 puntos
por cada pregunta que respondes
correctamente en la tabla de arriba q
representa el número de preguntas que
contestas correctamente en tu
cuestionario y p representa el número
total de puntos que obtienes en tu
cuestionario la relación entre estas dos
variables puede ser expresada por la
siguiente ecuación p es igual a 5 q
donde p son los puntos que obtienes y q
el número de preguntas que contestas
correctamente podemos verlo en la tabla
si no contestas ninguna pregunta
correctamente entonces tienes 0 puntos
si q es igual a 0 5 por 0 es igual a 0
si contesta es una pregunta
correctamente tienes 1 por 5 5 puntos 2
preguntas correctas tienes 10 puntos 2
por 5 es igual a 10 3 por 5 es 15 así es
que esta correcta la tabla y luego nos
preguntan cuál de los siguientes
enunciados es correcto marca todos los
que apliquen pensemos en estos casos la
variable dependiente es el número de
puntos que obtienes cuando vemos lo que
nos están planteando aquí el número de
puntos que obtienes es
secuencia de las preguntas que contestas
correctamente
aquí no es el caso de que el maestro
dijera por ejemplo tienes 15 puntos
entonces tienes que contestar 3
preguntas correctamente es justo al
revés el número de respuestas correctas
es la variable independiente y eso está
determinando el número de puntos que
obtienes así es que el número de puntos
que obtienes es la variable dependiente
usualmente se expresa a la variable
dependiente como igual a una expresión
que contiene la variable independiente y
eso lo tenemos aquí que depende del
valor de q al multiplicar el número de
respuestas correctas por 5 obtiene este
la variable dependiente es el número de
puntos que obtienes la variable
dependiente es el número de preguntas
que contestas correctamente no ya
hablamos de eso esa es la variable
independiente la variable independiente
es el número de puntos que obtienes no
eso no es correcto es la variable
dependiente la variable independiente es
el número de preguntas que contestas
correctamente esto es verdad es la que
está determinando la variable
dependiente y podemos checar nuestra
respuesta